this is how government and five of us
these odds are terrible we need to watch
what Nathan let me get one chance to
save the galaxy twice here you stand
here a garden of the galaxy guardians of
the galaxy why would we be the guardians
of the galaxy it'll be here any minute
is that a rifle you don't know what a
rifle looks like did swords were your
thing and gun for mine but I guess we
both doing guns now I just didn't know
that
I see it within you fear jealousy
betrayal is it argue who to cleanse the
universe of this weakness
you know they told me you people were
conceited douchebags but that isn't true
at all
dude I'm using my wrong
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so with saving the galaxy again we're
really gonna be able to jack up our
bright super two-time galaxy Davis
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
sometimes the thing you're searching for
your whole life it's right there by your
side all along you're right you can with
God
[Music]
no family
familiar
after all these years I'd found you and
who the hell are you I'm your dad
[Music]
you